now you're being honored with the Allan
Slater war tonight how does it feel to
get this recognition at this stage in
your career oh my gosh it feels like so
crazy and so early I mean I never
expected this especially now in like I'm
from here and from the suburb so every
time we'd come to the city and we'd walk
on that Street I would see all the stars
and it was just something that was like
way in the future like something so
far-fetched you know in something so far
from my own life that I never even
thought of even dreaming about it
because I was like yeah this is like for
like legends and so weird it's crazy
that I'm here I'm like are you sure you
guys right person I'm very very honored
I'm so honored I'm so excited and
there's nothing like your own country
being proud of you you know so I feel
super honored and flattered and you've
been very busy you're out on tour you
just released a Christmas song so how
are you feeling I feel good I feel
exhausted I'm not gonna lie we were
touring for like nine months straight he
went on the road with Shawn Mendes and
did her own tour so it was like non-stop
so I'm just excited to like get back in
my little hub that I call home and write
more music and just chill be with family
and celebrate Christmas which I'm
excited about you released an EP but can
we expect like another full-length album
coming from you um you could definitely
expect that it's not like officially in
the works but I've been writing a bunch
so probably that's my favorite part of
what I do so I would love to release as
many albums as I can so yeah and being
on tour with Shawn this summer what was
that like and anything that surprised
you about him that you learned about him
being on tour um man it was so much fun
so much fun I think trying to think of
anything that surprised me I mean I've
known him for years so I kind of already
knew him I think I was definitely
surprised at how disciplined he is
though cuz anytime I've seen him
obviously was outside of tour so I
didn't know I didn't see him in his work
setting too much but seeing how
disciplined he is and how much he cares
for his voice and he'll be on vocal rest
for like hours a day won't eat like a
million different foods like to protect
his voice he's so disciplined I guess up
I like the crack of dawn I don't know
what he does but it's really it was
actually really inspiring to see that
because I'm the opposite I don't take
care of myself at all and I should so it
like okay I gotta get on my game if he's
the same if he if he's that way I gotta
like do that too so yeah and he just got
the Grammy nomination with Camilla have
you talked to him about it at all I
haven't actually no I haven't well I
mean like yeah yeah it's I haven't seen
him in a while but it's really awesome
I'm so happy for him I saw him the last
time he was nominated for in my blood
and it's not his first one and I won't
be his last and I'm like so excited for
him so and her of course thank you thank
you one more question
biggest highlight of your career like
what's the moment that stands out to you
um
biggest moment that stands out to me I
know it sounds kind of cheesy to say
this but this is like pretty up there
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna lie um this
probably the Grammy of course and I
don't know I don't know sorry I feel
like I'm just a jumbling on my words
yeah this definitely and the Grammy
probably thank you